hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares now I'm getting back into it
which means that I need to dive deep
into the depths of Hell once more and
I'm not entirely sure what I'm supposed
to do next maybe I'm supposed to oh wait
no wasn't there a path to the right
after I go through and meet my buddy
Bubba
after Bubba over here hello Bubba hi
Baba
oh hey Bubba see what is wrong with your
pop I like arms that's not okay yeah oh
god oh okay I thought I didn't know that
was a tree I thought that was something
else entirely so there's got to be
something in one of these smaller rooms
in here or else is just gonna be nothing
and I'm gonna be wandering the halls
forever and ever
man that is a disconcerting noise in the
background over there one thing about
this and I've said it many times before
but often when a game lacks
Oh sounds like Freddy Krueger when
Johnny Depp got mashed into mush oh that
is just about the most disturbing thing
I've ever seen I was just about to say
something about how the graphics weren't
up to par but yeah mixture of that and
the sounds good God
oh hey is that a brain or is that a face
is that beign oh man what is this Oh
someone said in the comments about this
they said don't sit in the chair this
chair wasn't supposed to sit in why am I
not supposed to sit here what is that
wait I thought I do I see something
moving up yeah I thought I saw something
oh I'm probably not supposed to be doing
this this is probably very bad for me
although I feel peaceful its kind of
reversed snowing or someone with a lot
of dandruff just walk through here
either one I don't know which one I'm
more happy about oh it's so peaceful oh
good yeah someone in the comments
mentioned that there was a chair and I
wasn't supposed to sit in it or maybe I
was I can't exactly remember it sounds
good I mean there's still the picture of
the brain oh whoa whoa that what that
was not there before
yeah that's less comforting yeah so this
this seems bad now that I'm looking at
it more closely what is that
what wait a minute that's the who I
think I think I see something else
around the door ooh ah I might be I mean
there's a lot of stuff going on so I
might just be tricking my soul what is
that oh that is not a good sound oh hi
whoa ah buddy those other hey stop that
now ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh I shouldn't have sat in
this chair huh
I shouldn't have sat in this chair oh hi
wow you're becoming more and more Oh God
oh that's not good
oh that's not good I thought I noticed
something else has happened but he's oh
it's good I I did it's getting darker Oh
oh no no I'm blacking out just as I was
having my moment of clarity no sorry
this is the most interesting thing
that's happened to me today
I don't know what that was I'm assuming
that I could get up from this chair at
any moment but I don't want to I want to
see how far down the rabbit hole really
goes can I even see his face anymore
weird weird okay is that the end of the
ride getting quieter I might as well
wait around till something else happens
oh whoa Oh sent me wait a minute was
that me is that me is that me
oh did I leave a piece of myself behind
after being in that chair oh that's not
a oh I can't see in the chair anymore
alright buddy I'm gonna assume that
you're gonna haunt me later that was a
that was a journey what was that all
about so so cool and weird but cool I
don't know oh god hey how's it going
there okay oh I do not like this somehow
Spooky's House of jump-scares man the
developer did a good job on this one I
can tell you don't you that much okay oh
that's right I got the insertable ah
that's right so the insertable goes in
the office which was behind the main
desk so I can save but I don't know if I
actually did any good so it sort of was
he right oh no oh maybe here no it was
in one of these it was in an office
somewhere some dumb where ah here we go
okay haha oh that's bringing back
memories of doom oh yeah I want to go
down that stairwell it looks comforting
and full of fun
now Who am I to talk i sat in a chair
that probably stole my soul oh I can't
go down oh okay I just press e on it
Oh God all right fine we're gonna on you
douche what do you got for me
there's someone behind me okay all right
cool all right going well for me I'm
having a good time
how about you guys you having fun up you
stop that now I want to look bye
stop it Oh God Oh one of these days
looking behind me is gonna get back to
me you may oh god oh god hi sorry I
forgot that okay so this is a weird
chopped off tentacle on the stairwell
nothing to worry about I mean this is
Japanese Hospital what what
haha okay oh god man this just never
ends does it
oh man when can I go back to my happy
place what is that
it feels cold why did I touch it it's
litterally pus and blood ah all right
that's a comforting door sound to the
walls feel cold
maybe if I find it oh hey whoa whoa whoa
whoa baby vagina face thing ah weird huh
I just realized what I said oh my god
that's just what I saw I sighed that's
the description oh this is gonna be a
puzzle it's gonna be a puzzle isn't it
I'm gonna be lost forever
I'm never gonna find my save point I'm
never gonna find my save oh god how did
it get back here did I get a full circle
this is a bunch of baloney
oh man when am I gonna meet up with
babyface oh hello
uh okay then are these chairs that will
also steal my soul are these boxes that
may or may not steal my soul okay fine
you know like II mean Oh like but
there's gotta be something else down
here some other way to go I mean I'm
assuming it's not randomly generated in
it's actually just a specific PI how's
it going babyface uh what is with you
what is shut up your weirdo oh god oh
god no oh he's he's doing a spin attack
he's gonna get me
okay.i man the sound - okay I'm not a
hundred percent sure which way to go now
but did I come from this way it's hard
to remember oh this is a long hallway uh
anybody want some maybe it's not a long
hallway at all maybe I'm just being a
fool
oh no oh no oh no did I get trapped in
an endless hallway there was a room in
the original game that had something
like this oh god no oh no oh no oh no I
don't wanna die I don't wanna die I
don't wanna die
I already lost my soul let me keep my
life just please let me hold on for one
more second one more second of sweet
delicious life okay I don't think I can
I don't think it's getting me anywhere
but the music's getting louder that's
for damn sure
oh god oh no oh no yeah is getting
nowhere
okay trying to go back which is probably
oh wow I got nowhere oh man I am a doof
that did not help me at all rude baby
where is it where is he where is he
Oh see him ah how does that even
possible you frigging weirdo okay is
this way to go
where's I got Dan the where am I now
so where does this go
okay this doesn't make a layout of this
doesn't make a hundred percent of sense
Oh goddamnit what is with this okay so
I'm gonna go back this way
and then I'm gonna make a right and that
should lead me back to the entrance
question mark and if it doesn't that
means that I'm completely lost
oh it did not baby maybe where's baby oh
that was the broken day I don't know
where he is okay this is the entrance
yeah okay so if this is the entrance
that means if I go out and then down
that hallway that I went before I should
be in a new place right about
nananana
now unless unless I'm wrong I might be
wrong I am 100% wrong gosh dang it what
a load of porpoise fork all right so I'm
gonna figure this out yeah this way I
thought okay I'm gonna figure this out
and get to you get back to you guys with
the next episode so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know if I'm
doing something horribly wrong in the
comments down below and as always I will
see you in the next video why what is
this happening
Sonic why